and then and then dog day happened how
did Dog Day happen I mean did you
obviously auditioned for it yeah oh yeah
did you who'd you audition for Sydney
lamet the director and uh and Al Pacino
and the producers Marty alfond and uh
Marty bregman Marty bregman was Al's yes
manager I think at the time were you
nervous in the room
well you know it's such a cool character
who's kind of like the nerves get to him
anyway in a way well actually it's
interesting because it I don't know
about you I I and you tell me when you
read something that really fits and you
understand it and you know what you're
doing then the nerves are there but it's
not about oh my God I'm gonna [ __ ] this
up it's more about
oh man I I have to ride this right I
have to ride this at the moment I have
to feel that I have to really get into
this right now and the nerves help
yeah they don't help when you're when
you're unsure now do you do anything to
prepare before you go into a room when
you're about to go into a room is there
something you do any kind of practice
that you have any breathing or do you
just go you don't think about it if uh
if I'm prepared I'd basically just go
uh yeah it doesn't really I I don't
think it necessarily I mean you know I I
got advice one time a long time ago when
I was a young actor of just think of
them when you walk in the room think of
them sitting on a toilet
everybody you're auditioning for that's
the common denominator we all have to
take a dump at some point in our lives
right yes and they're not you know there
there's nothing extra special about
these people but for the dog they
audition it was really interesting
because first of all this was it was a
great script yeah it won an Academy
Award it was nominated for eight Academy
Awards I think and had won for best
screenplay Frank Pearson right right and
uh and I immediately understood this
character
and I I think part of that was
understanding the otherness
of somebody who is a his body is foreign
to him yeah and in my case my psyche was
kind of foreign I was you know I was
this Greek America of 100 American
full-blooded Greek and so I understood
uh uh Leon shermers the name of the guy
in the movie yeah and I I just got it
and and so I went in very prepared did
you read without did you read what I
read without yeah yeah we read the
telephone scene right the telephone
scene I loved that scene because you're
like you're holding your buttons on your
shirt or something you're like that
comes from a I stole that from a
photograph of the guy coming being let
out of the police car and his clutching
his robe around him to to maintain his
privacy you know yeah I just thought it
was like a nervous cool little tip that
you're doing I stole it I stole it
did you when you let me ask you when you
finish this audition and you're you just
read without did you get any sort of
affirmation or any kind of like
I it was obvious that it was going well
and Sydney Lamont came over to me and he
gave me the best note I think probably
I've ever gotten from a director what
was it he said because I was playing it
very sort of Blanche Dubois right right
and Sydney said a little less Blanche
Dubois a little more Queen's housewife
when you come back wow
and that was the note that went oh oh oh
okay all right now I know how to locate
this guy
and also that he's not this this what
this um elevated
Queen he was a queen's housewife
and you just didn't you knew exactly
what he wanted so the next time I came
in I read with Al and I did you know I
was it was I was talking you know
wow that is so cool I could just yeah I
could just see the room I mean did you
know after that the the next time you
read was there something that made you
go I got this [ __ ] thing yeah yeah
what was it
but just that you know there was a real
sort of palpable sense of of everybody
being genuinely
uh we really liked that that was great
and you don't often have that in an
audition because people always play it
so cool yeah you know but you let it all
out there you're like this is the role
this is the part